Would you recommend for those nights when you just can't get to sleep or feel like I'm really in a
deep sleep? What would you recommend if you can't get to sleep or you can't get into a deep sleep?
Well, if you can't fall asleep, then you start thinking that it's you could have met melatonin
issues, taking melatonin, taking some things that will calm your brain. Many times we can't
fall asleep because our brain is too revved up. It's actually fired at a frequency that's a high
beta wave. So normally if you're wide awake and you're focused and you're listening like everybody's
doing right now, your brain is in a beta wave. Or if I'm boring you to death, your brain is in
an alpha wave and you're just about ready to fall asleep. That's probably most people listening to
me right now. But that's what you want to get your brain down to in order to fall asleep. So
maybe you should just listen to some videos of mine and then we'll get your brain into an alpha sleep
and you'll just fall right asleep. Thank you Dr. Cutters. You're such a help. You help me fall asleep
every night. Well, I'm hopefully getting, but maybe not. Getting your brain to an alpha wave is
important and one of the things that hinders that is watching TV, watching screen time, looking at your
computer, looking at your phone, all screens, all computer screens, all television screens, your
phone screen is firing at a frequency of 60 hertz. So you're actually in what's called in training
your brain at 60 hertz. What a high beta wave is about 30, 35 hertz, you're firing your brain at 60
hertz. It could be difficult for you to fall asleep at night because your brain is in this high
hertz dopamine reaction. So you can't get to sleep. There's other things that have to do with
your own transmitters because you're actually firing more glutamate as a glutamate as a newer transmitter.
So it gets your brain fired up and you're thinking about all the things that you need to do tomorrow.
That's because of brain and treatment as well at least to place a part of that. So try to take some
herbs that will help calm down your brain. It can be helpful. Magnesian L-theanate. We have
product called insomnetol that has some calming herbs. Different adaptogens can be calming. Melatolid
can be helpful. If you wake up at night, you can't fall back asleep. That can be because of a cortisol
issue, actually, too low of cortisol. So you might be burning the candle at two ends during the day.
Burning out your adredals and you have too low of a cortisol output in the middle of the night.
That's what has to keep you asleep. You need a good healthy cortisol output in the middle of the night
to stimulate a breakdown of glycogen in your liver in order to feed your brain so that your brain
has enough glucose. So your brain is trying to wake you up and get you to walk around in the middle of
the night so that you'll start to create glucose through gluconeogenesis with the breakdown of muscle.
That's the only way you can do it. So that can be an issue. It can be because of lack of protein intake.
That can be an issue. So make sure you're eating some chicken before you're going to bed. That might
be helpful. So things like that, the things that you want to look at. I do have several blog posts and
videos on this, too, that might be helpful.